la date du 12 janvier 2019 loin d'être
oublié l'explosion rue de trévise qui a
fait quatre morts des dizaines de
blessés et plusieurs centaines de
sinistrés est aujourd'hui au coeur des
débats
une nouvelle réunion est organisée ce
jeudi au ministère de la justice sur
l'indemnisation des victimes qui n'ont
pas été conviés pour chaque pas qu'on
fait pour pour se reconstruire en fait
deux pas en arrière dès qu'on a affaire
à eux c'est des démarches continuelle
c'est toutes les semaines c'est décédé
absence de réponse a parfois des
douzaines de mails et cet immobilisme
il devient insupportable ça patauge en
fait on a l'impression que chacun se
refilent la patate chaude si on peut
dire les choses comme ça aujourd'hui
enfin les avocats ont déposé un référé
pour
que grdf soit aussi me
en accusation enfin qu'on soit aussi mis
en examen
parce que il ya l'effet du gaz qui a
c'est l'effet du gaz qui a créé et qui a
fait ses dégâts la seule la ville de
paris et les assureurs sont invités à
débattre place vendôme
il sera question d'une convention
appelée accord-cadre si elle permettrait
une indemnisation amiable intégrale et
rapide des préjudices de toutes les
victimes
elle est loin de faire l'unanimité la
maire du 9e arrondissement
delphine bürkli à elle choisi son camp
on avance petit à petit pour reconnaître
les victimes et moins ce que je souhaite
et c'est mon combat depuis deux ans
vraiment c'est que les victimes de
trévise soit des victimes comme les
autres et qu'elles soient traités comme
tels voilà ce sont des victimes d'un
accident collectif d'une ampleur
incroyable on va pas attendre la fin des
procédures judiciaires qui vont
peut-être durer cinq dix quinze ans pour
qu'ils obtiennent réparation de leur
côté les associations pousse un cri d'
alerte dans une lettre envoyée vendredi
aux principaux acteurs du dossier
nous attendons depuis des mois la
signature d'un accord cadre de l' objet
l'indemnisation des victimes
nous souhaitons prendre part à la
réunion du 10 juin
si nous ne sommes pas conviés nous ne
participerons à aucune réunion à
l'avenir à ce stade une information
judiciaire est toujours en cours pour
déterminer les responsabilités pénales
de ce drame
la mairie de paris et le syndic de
l'immeuble devant lequel s'est produite
l'explosion ont été mis en examen en
septembre 2020 pour homicides et
blessures involontaires
si la tenue d'un procès ne se profile
pas avant des années
la question des indemnisations peut se
traiter sans attendre l'issue judiciaire